prot
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat à suivre ce matin sur notre
antenne à les travaux de la mission
d'information du sénat sur le médiator
les sénateurs réfléchissent à une
refonte du système de contrôle des
médicaments
ils ont entendu bruno toussaint le
directeur de la revue médicale
indépendante prescrire c'est un des
premiers qui s'étaient élevés contre les
risques que pouvaient faire peser sur
les patients la prescription ne médiator
ce médicament était en effet suspecté de
provoquer de graves troubles cardiaques
c'est donc cette audition que je vous
propose de suivre tout de suite bonne
matinée à tous bon mes chers collègues
que il faut pas que nous prenions de
retard aujourd'hui parce que nous avons
une matinée chargée quatre auditions et
nous allons nous avons plaisir donc pour
la première audition d'accueillir
monsieur bruno toussaint qui est du
directeur de la revue prescrire qui nous
souhaitons bien entendu ta bienvenue et
que nous remercions d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation
je voudrais tout d'abord lui rappeler un
que cette audition est ouverte à la
presse et fait l'objet d'un
enregistrement en vue de sa diffusion
sur le site du sénat est de la chaîne
public sénat
et je vous demanderais puisque cette
audition et public en application de
l'article l 4113 tirs et 13 du code de
la santé publique de nous faire
connaître si vous en avez vos liens avec
des entreprises produisant aux
exploitants des produits de santé aux
services de conseil intervenant sur ces
produits et si vous attendiez par
l'affirmative je serais très très
surpris ce serait vraiment un scoop
alors je vous écoute
appuyez sur le bouton rectangulaire
c'est rouge là est ce que ça marche
je ne sais pas vous me direz oui oui ça
a l'air de marcher
merci merci d'avoir invité prescrire
bien sûr et effectivement comme tout
rédacteurs de prescrire je n'ai aucun
lien d'intérêt avec aucune firme du
domaine de la santé
merci monsieur toussaint donc si vous le
si vous le souhaitez donc vous avez la
possibilité de faire une intervention
liminaire de feng d'une dizaine de
minutes
comme vous le souhaitez et ensuite je
passerai la parole à madame la
rapporteur qui vous posera un certain
nombre de questions et ensuite à mes
collègues qui feront de même s'ils le
souhaitent
donc monsieur tout ça vous avez la
parole merci je vais tâcher d'être bref
je crois que l'essentiel est de répondre
à vos questions et le fait que
l'émission enfin la séance soit
enregistrée et est parfaitement public
est une chose très importante en la
matière un des éléments du drame du
médiator qui a fait donc des milliers de
victimes des personnes atteintes par ce
médicament handicapés ou mortes
un des éléments importants c'est
effectivement le secret la rétention
d'informations et donc il est très
important que en antidote
il y ait au contraire beaucoup de
transparence et d'information de
l'ensemble des personnes voilà donc pour
nous au médiator et non pas un cas isolé
une exception une histoire française
comme on entend trop souvent dire c'est
au contraire le révélateur de d'un
ensemble de dysfonctionnements graves du
système d'administration du médicament
que ce soit l'autorisation de mise sur
le marché ou sa surveillance et les
procédures de retrait du marché et ces
procédures n'ont rien de spécifiquement
français et ses dysfonctionnements n'ont
rien de spécifiquement français les
règles du jeu sont les mêmes à quelques
nuances près dans tous les pays
européens et même tout autour du monde
donc il est très important effectivement
que beaucoup de lumière toute la lumière
soit faite sur ce cas médiator parce
qu'il est très important dans tiré
beaucoup de leçons pour changer beaucoup
de choses en france et tout autour du
monde
je crois qu ensuite on a mis là un ordre
de grandeur des enjeux et je préfère
répondre à vos questions
très bien écouter nous allons tout de
suite passer aux questions de la mûre à
porter la parole
merci papa propos que vous venez
de tenir quels sont les
dysfonctionnements qu'il ya aujourd'hui
sur le marché en matière d'autorisations
et de retrait au niveau français au
niveau européen au niveau mondial et par
exemple est ce qu'il y a une différence
entre pour vous les dysfonctionnements
qu'il ya eu puisque on a le sénat a
conduit une mission aussi sur ce
médicament entre le vioxx et le médiator
autrement dit est-ce que finalement à
chaque retrait d'un médicament
le sénat l'assemblée nationale où
d'autres vont ils être amené à faire une
mission d'information
et est ce qu'il y à des
dysfonctionnements que nous avions
d'ailleurs déjà pointé nous au sénat qui
devrait être très rapidement mise en
application
mais oui bien sûr alors est ce que vous
pouvez dire concrètement pour vous les
dysfonctionnements qui a au niveau de
l'autorisation et du retrait non
seulement au niveau français mais dans
d'autres pays
oui sur les mêmes problèmes partout à
quelques nuances près mais vraiment les
mêmes problèmes partout et vous avez
tout à fait raison
le désastre du vioxx a été bien plus
médiatisé f1 est apparu comme bien plus
américain un médicament américains et
les seules statistiques sérieuses qu'on
ait eue avec encore beaucoup
d'incertitudes sur l'ampleur du dégât
l'ampleur du nombre de victimes ont été
américaine est en france on n'a
quasiment rien su mais les ingrédients
sont les mêmes
et effectivement tous les
dysfonctionnements qui ont été mis à
jour
après le scandale du vioxx y compris
bien sûr dans l' enquête sénatoriale
tous et tous ces dysfonctionnements sont
toujours à l'oeuvre puisque sensiblement
rien aucune des préconisations faites à
l'époque n'ont été mises en oeuvre
donc les conditions n'ont pas changé et
nous en sommes toujours là et donc il y
à une médiator et si rien ne change
encore il y aura d'autres désastre de
grande ampleur
c'est évident pour nous c'est évident
alors si on reprend la liste mais qui
est déjà connu
probablement
au départ il y à ce concept d' harry
même qui est accordée au vu d'un dossier
qui est monté par la firme elle-même
donc la firme est placé dans un conflit
d'intérêts radical enfin massif
d'origine puisque les pouvoirs publics
demandent à la sciences pharmaceutiques
d'évaluer elle même le médicament dont
elle demande d'autorisation en vue de
gagner de l'argent
alors c'est un conflit d'intérêts est
massif il faut que la recherche sur le
médicament et on sait en particulier la
recherche clinique ne soit plus financé
majoritairement par l'industrie
pharmaceutique
sa place l'industrie dans un conflit
d'intérêts insolubles à notre avis alors
ensuite il y a bien sûr les critères
d'obtention die même temps qu' il n'est
pas réellement exigé exiger des preuves
de progrès thérapeutique apportées par
le nouveau médicament par rapport aux
moyens dont on dispose déjà
nous serons confrontés à des médicaments
qui font courir des risques injustifiés
aux patients puisque dans le système
actuel
on voit bien qu'une firme peut obtenir
une autorisation de mise sur le marché
pour un médicament qu'il importe
aucun progrès par rapport à ce qu'on a
déjà dans la panoplie thérapeutique et
que même si les effets indésirables
paraissent acceptables
malgré tout il y a suffisamment de
moyens de promotion pour convaincre
beaucoup de prescripteurs de prescrire
ce médicament qui n'apporte pourtant
rien de concret rien de aucun progrès
pour mieux soigner
donc l'affairé rentable sans dégager
aucun progrès et bien entendu étant
donné les inconnus qu'il ya autour des
effets indésirables dans le dossier
d'amm m le dossier d'autorisation de
mise en marché
il n'a porté que sur quelques centaines
quelques milliers parfois dans le
meilleur des cas quelques centaines de
patients bien sûr une fois que le
médicament est distribué largement dans
la population sur des centaines de
milliers de personnes des milliers de
personnes on découvre de nouveaux effets
indésirables et parfois très graves et
parfois moins rare qu'on ne pensait oui
continuez se termine non pas encore
allez-y vous ont repris jeudi allait
conclure que donc le système actuel en
france et ailleurs d'autorisation de
mise sur le marché est trop perméable à
des médicaments qui n'apporte aucun
progrès voir qu'ils sont des régressions
thérapeutique et malgré et malgré malgré
cela les sciences pharmaceutiques ont
suffisamment de moyens de promotion pour
gagner de l'argent avec de tels
médicaments et donc le système perdure
et donc les patients la population
restent exposés à beaucoup beaucoup trop
d'un médicament plus dangereux qu'utiles
parle on parle on concrètement ils
viennent d'être publié une liste de 77
médicaments dont par exemple un
médicament pris par énormément de
personnes qui s'appelle le levothyrox
dont certains médecins nous disent que
je ne suis pas médecin un simple citoyen
que si on leur retire et cette
prescription
il aurait des problèmes théorie diadhiou
conséquent et autres alors par exemple
par rapport à cette liste et par rapport
aux cas du levothyrox qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire si vous permettez mal
alors à 20 jours est ajoutée une pluie
de questions j'ai fait une petite
analyse très rapide un de ces soixante
dix et théo et j'ai constaté que parmi
ces 77 médicaments
il y en avait 25 qui avait un smr 5
alors je m'interroge est-ce qui serait
pas plus simple de retirer purement et
simplement ces médicaments qui sont
inutiles et qui paradoxalement sont
considérés quand même comme dangereux
puisque il bénéficie d'une d'une
surveillance particulière donc c'est la
question annexe que je pose à laquelle
je vous demande si vous le souhaitez
sauvé de répondre alors cette liste et
cette liste de 67000 77 médicaments sous
surveillance est particulièrement
confuse et a fait naître beaucoup
d'angoissé d'interrogation will
confusion enfin elle est alors on va pas
revenir là dessus trop longtemps bien en
tout cas cette liste qui est important
c'est que cette liste mélange des
situations extrêmement différente
extrêmement différente donc son seul
avantage est de permettre de commencer à
aborder le sujet en grand puisque
beaucoup de personnes sont concernées ou
se sentent concernés alors pour
reprendre deux premiers un point
levothyrox levothyrox est le nom
commercial
la substance active c'est la
lévothyroxine c'est l'hormone humaine
produite par la thyroïde et qui
effectivement absolument indispensable à
de nombreuses personnes qui n'ont plus
de thyroïde parce qu'on a opéré ou parce
qu elle l a été irradié enfin bref ou
don de la thyroïde est devenu inefficace
improductives pour telle ou telle
maladie en raison de telle ou telle
maladie
donc ce médicament est absolument
essentiel c'est certain il est connu
depuis très longtemps des décennies
puisque là ce qui a motivé si j'ai bien
compris la présence de ce médicament sur
cette liste ce n'est pas tant la
substance bien sûr mais certains
génériques certaines copies et il y
aurait selon l' agence du médicament
des signalements d'inefficacité de
certains génériques
donc le problème n'est pas du tout la
surveillance de la lévothyroxine en
elle-même qui est très bien connu ni du
médicament leem au tir hawks proprement
parler la spécialité levothyrox mais les
qualités ou les noms qualité de certains
génériques ses dires de médicaments de
copies qui sont autorisés par l'afssaps
c'est donc un problème de fabrication
d'inspection des copies des génériques
et ça n'a aucun rapport avec les
conditions d'autorisation de mise sur le
marché de nouveaux médicaments etc
c'est un problème très particulier qui
n'a pas de rapport avec médiator des
choses comme cela
par contre c'est très choquant bien sûr
de voir ce médicament sous surveillance
alors ma question oui oui je veux bien
alors deuxièmement 35 parler donc alors
à smr 5 amélioration du service médical
rendu
selon la commission de la transparence
rattaché à la haute autorité de santé et
le niveau 5 comme on le sait
paradoxalement ce n'est pas le cinq
étoiles c'est au contraire le niveau
zéro c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas
d'amélioration du service médical rendu
bien alors donc des médicaments qui ont
un accès mer 5 une asmr 5 a priori
n'apporte aucun progrès par rapport à ce
qu'on a déjà à disposition sur le marché
français dans ces conditions c'est sûr
qu'on est en droit d'être
particulièrement exigeants sur les
effets indésirables de ces médicaments
car s'ils n'apportent aucun progrès le
peu de régression qu'ils vont apporter
en tant qu effets indésirables devrait
suffire à les évincer du marché
alors pour autant est-ce que ces
médicaments sont ils utiles ils sont
inutiles dans le centre ils font double
emploi
bon ça c'est certain alors devrait-il
être retirés moi je n'ai pas analysé et
la lisent la liste sous cet angle donc
je ne peux pas aller plus loin mais je
peux apporter ces éléments de réflexion
je vais dit que quand un médicament
était mise sur le marché pour vous la
principale le principal obstacle était
le fait que effectivement la recherche
clinique et est financé par l'industrie
pharmaceutique dans la mission nous
avons conduit sur le vioxx
il nous avait été dit je me demande
d'ailleurs si c'est pas par votre des
personnes de votre revue que lorsqu'un
médicament été mis sur le marché il
était mis sur le marché selon un modèle
pasteurien alors que ce modèle qui passe
rien donc est appliquée lorsqu'il sort à
une population qui a une pathologie
chronique et donc qui va qui va prendre
ce médicament dans le temps a donc est
ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi et que c'est
quelque chose de fondamental qu'on ne
voit pas forcément un dysfonctionnement
entre la norme
finalement qui permet aux médicaments
d'être sur le marché la norme
pharmaceutique et clinique par rapport à
la population qui va prendre médicament
est dans la norme n'est pas adapté
finalement à la population qui va
prendre ce médicament est ce qui est pas
un dysfonctionnement là aussi mais il ya
beaucoup de dysfonctionnements
donc le financement de la recherche
l'ordre du financement mais de la norme
et du modèle et qui est quelque chose de
fondamental
on a plusieurs normes qui font
fonctionner un certain nombre de
systèmes qui sont quelque part invisible
et à partir du moment où la norme
explose la notion de par exemple de
travail qui fondent le système de la
sécurité sociale et puis quand on est
dans un système où il ya de plus en plus
de chômage n'est pas on voit qu'elle
explose mais il faut qu'ils aient de
plus en plus de chômage pour que elle
explose et qu'elle soit visible aux yeux
de tous
est ce que finalement il y as
exclusivement la question du financement
de l'industrie pharmaceutique par
rapport à la recherche clinique
ou est ce qu'il y à aussi autres sauf
deux qui est peut-être aussi
fondamentale par rapport à la norme par
rapport à un homme je n'ai pas
l'impression par rapport au financement
des firmes pharmaceutiques elle-même
louis dans le système actuel les firmes
pharmaceutiques sont incités à à
conquérir des parts de marché plus large
des parts de marché d'un marché qui va
être chronique et qui va concerner
beaucoup de gens autres je veux dire par
là que l'intérêt des firmes
pharmaceutiques actuellement est de
vendre le plus de médicaments le plus
longtemps possible au plus de personnes
possible donc avec ce modèle là beaucoup
de firmes font beaucoup d'efforts pour
conquérir des parts de marché de maladie
qu'elle ne guérissent pas qu'elles le
prétendent pas guérir avec leurs
médicaments
c'est ce qu'on voit avec le diabète non
insulinodépendant le diabète de type 2
qui concerne des millions de personnes
en français est partout dans tous les
pays
et aucun des médicaments actuels dont
pourtant certains son controversé
médiator je ne reviens pas dessus
le retrait de l'avandia rosiglitazone
l'année dernière en europe pioglitazone
actos qui est sur la sellette pour les
questions de cancer de la vessie tous
ces médicaments ne guérissent absolument
rien du diabète
il faut les prendre indéfiniment pour
espérer prévenir une partie des
complications c'est la même chose pour
l'hypercholestérolémie
aucun médicament ne guérit rien du tout
à ce problème là simplement il faut le
prendre au long cours pour diminuer les
risques cardio les complications
cardiovasculaires de même l'hypertension
et c'est donc il n'y a plus beaucoup de
recherches sur des médicaments qui vise
à acquérir un problème il n'y a plus
beaucoup de recherches sur les anti
infectieux
alors on sait guérir la tuberculose ce
formidable pendant longtemps c'était une
maladie chronique finissait par
remporter beaucoup de personnes on a des
antituberculeux en quelques mois c'est
guéri on en parle le plus pourvu qu'on
ait accès mais ça c'est encore autre
chose
bon dans le cas du sida nous sommes
entre les deux nous ne nous n'avons pas
de médicaments qui guérissent le sida
nous avons des médicaments qui
maîtrisent l'infection pour la très
grande majorité des personnes pendant de
nombreuses années
alors c'est formidable mais on n'a pas
guéri bon si ou ont tout à l'heure vous
parlez du vioxx et de la mission qui a
suivi vioxx rofécoxib est un enfant anti
inflammatoire qui ne guérit rien il n'a
aucune prétention à nos fins les
médicaments n'ont pas de prétention
d'ailleurs mais ça en tout cas ses
promoteurs n'ont aucune prétention
absolument guérir quoi que ce soit san
san lille ça ne traite aucune cause
particulière de médicaments ce sont des
médicaments symptomatiques en
particulier une grosse clientèle bien
entendu si je puis dire de ce médicament
c'est les rhumatismes chronique
l'arthrose la polyarthrite rhumatoïde
etc et les anti inflammatoires ne
guérissent rien de cela ils diminuent en
partie les symptômes pour une partie des
patients
et puis quand on arrête le médicament
banc de revenus au point de départ alors
la maladie à ces fluctuations et
heureusement on peut avoir de temps en
temps des rémissions et se passer un peu
de médicaments mais je crois qu'il ne
faut pas trop garder en tête que la
recherches actuelles portent sur des
médicaments qui viserait essentiellement
à guérir les maladies au contraire les
firmes se sont entêtés h à chercher à
gagner des parts de marché sur des
maladies chroniques qu'elle ne
guérissent pas qu'elle ne guérissent pas
rapporteur est écrit en mai vous avez
des mets 97
vous avez publié un certain nombre
d'articles sur le médiator à quelle date
finalement ce médicament aurait dû être
retiré de la vente
et puisque vous avez par exemple sur le
médiator écrit des articles des 97
est ce que vous avez sur d'autres
médicaments écrit un certain nombre
d'articles dont personne ne s'occupe
finalement aujourd'hui et qui pourrait
aujourd'hui être retirés de la vente
parce qu on est sur une mission
concernant le médiator mais sur
l'ensemble de la problématique
médicamenteuse qui aussi a pour objet
d'essayer de de faire le clair et en
même temps de restaurer la confiance
parce que sa femme de personnes doivent
aussi prendre des médicaments
et c'est important aussi de le dire en
sachant que tout médicament a des effets
aussi un désir oui tout à fait il y à
des médicaments qu'ils rendent des
services magnifique je parlais tout à
l'heure tuberculose ou infections par le
vih qu'il est évident qu'il y a des
médicaments magnifique bon c'est bien
certain
raison de plus à notre avis pour être
exigeant pour faire le tri parmi tous
ces médicaments garder les médicaments
qu'ils rendent des services importants
est éliminée nous débarrasser des
médicaments de second tendre voir qu'ils
sont plus néfastes dangereux qu'utiles
et il y en a beaucoup beaucoup dans les
pharmacies à la maison une pharmacie
familiale les pharmacies d'officine les
pharmacies d'hôpitaux dans les traités
de médecine dans les périodiques
d'information dans le cerveau des
médecins dans le cerveau des pharmaciens
dans le cerveau des infirmiers etc
il ya beaucoup de tri à faire et
beaucoup de choses à évincer pour au
contraire se concentrer sur les
médicaments importants et les progrès
réels depuis 30 ans
une des rubriques de prescrire s'appelle
rayon des nouveautés pour faire
justement le tri parmi les nouveaux
médicaments pour mettre en évidence ce
qui apporte quelque chose pour soigner
mieux et ces médicaments valent le coup
effectivement et mettre de côté leur est
bien alors médias aujourd'hui ce que
vous pensez que l'aspirine serez mis sur
le marché
alors la mise sur le marché et l'intérêt
d'un médicament se pose toujours dans
une situation précise
c'est comme tout objet d'élire dans la
vie ça dépend de ce qu'on en fait alors
l'aspirine en tant que antiagrégants
plaquettaires c'est à dire à toutes
petites doses pour limiter le risque de
thrombose artérielle en particulier par
exemple après un infarctus du myocarde
oui c'est un médicament très utile kiki
ac qui a ses limites bien entendu ça
augmente aussi le risque d'hémorragie
mais c'est un médicament très utile
c'est le médicament de référence dans
cette situation très bien par contre à
titre de médicaments contre la fièvre ou
contre les douleurs
c'est totalement dépassé il n'y a pas de
raison de se servir de l'aspirine
aujourd'hui à part certaines habitudes
certaines traditions et le fait que le
médicament est encore son marché voilà
il faut bien toujours avoir en tête que
pour peser l'intérêt d'un médicament
il faut faire la balance bénéfices
risques est notre avis c'est une balance
est pas un rapport c'est une balance
penche d'un côté ou de l'autre dans une
situation précise pour des personnes
précises
il n'y a pas de médicaments qu'ils
soient absolument valable pour tout le
monde
ou au contraire forcément néfaste pour
tout le monde ça ça doit s'analyser
situation par situation alors vous
m'aviez demandé médiator 1997
alors effectivement nous avons en 1997
publié de texte d' analyse approfondie
de la balance bénéfice-risque du
benfluorex puisque son vrai nom s'est
tout de même d'un flot rex et vous savez
que l' avantage de cette v séries c'est
ce au rex à la fin qui nous rappelle que
c'est un anorexigène donc un coupe faim
cette même décisif dans cette affaire
bien donc nous avons publié
effectivement deux analyse approfondie
de la balance bénéfice risque de ce
benfluorex dans les deux situations
autorisées à l'époque c'est à dire en
résumé sans ergoter sur lumeau le
diabète et les hyperlipidémie et nous
avons constaté que
il n'y avait pas de preuves de
d'efficacité tangible de ce médicament
ni dans un cas ni dans l'autre
c'est à dire aucune preuve de
l'efficacité préventive sur les
complications de ces de ces troubles
c'est encore une fois le diabète en soi
n'est pas le taux de sucre en soit dans
le sens n'est pas un problème
particulier le problème et les
complications au long cours rénal
oculaire cardio vasculaires unv à pas
détaillé le problème des complications
long cours de ceux du diabète et pour
les hyperlipidémie hypertriglycéridémies
c'est la même chose
7 c'est le même principe des
complications long cours donc en 1997
nous constatons que il n'y a aucune
preuve d'efficacité concrète de ce
médicament benfluorex sur ces
complications dans donc dans le plateau
efficacité bénéfices et bien
sensiblement rien un effet placebo un
effet sur quelques variables sanguine
mais sans traduction concrète dans la
vie les personnes donc très peu de
choses de l'autre côté est côté risque
et bien il y à cette parenté avec la fin
fut ramine la dexfenfluramine enfin
c'est un coupe-faim benfluorex encore
une fois et donc il nous paraît que ce
médicament va inévitablement exposés aux
effets indésirables de cette famille de
médicaments
même si nous avons à l'époque trouvé
très peu de données aucun autre avis il
y avait à l'époque et c'est ce que nous
avons écrit explicitement pas de raison
de se servir de ce médicament et nous
avons écrit qui est à notre avis il y
avait lieu de revoir sa présence sur le
marché et sa prise en charge par
l'assurance maladie
nous l'avons écrit aussi simplement que
ça je crois en conclusion du texte enfin
des deux textes puisque nous avons fait
deux volets donc à notre avis à
l'évidence en 1997 ce médicament devait
être retiré du marché
on aurait sûrement pu le voir plutôt
j'ai cru comprendre d actualité récente
que par exemple l'administration belge
avait examiné le dossier en 1977 je
crois et conclut déjà à cette époque le
même principe
côté efficacité rien de concret effets
indésirables fort probable les effets
indésirables des couffins et donc la
balance penche du mauvais côté c'est à
du côté du mauvais côté pour le
médicament du bon côté pour les patients
qui sont mis à l'abri des dangers de
cette chose là alors y en at il d'autres
sans aucun doute
chaque année grosso modo et les
statistiques précises sont publiés dans
prescrits et en particulier dans chaque
numéro de février
chaque année donc prescrire étudie les
nouveautés du marché
à leur arrivée sur le marché français et
chaque année il y à quelques médicaments
qui nous apparaissent plus dangereux
qu'utiles qui ne sont non pas des
progrès non pas des doubles emplois mais
des régressions thérapeutique des
régressions thérapeutique alors nous
n'obtenons pas la liste précise à
prescrire nous faisons nous cherchons à
apporter l'information ou fur et à
mesure au fil des mois au fil des années
à porter l'information aux
professionnels de santé à charge à eux
ensuite d'adapter d'utiliser ces
informations pour adapter leurs
décisions en les partageant avec les
patients concernés
c'est je fais un pas en arrière excusez
moi ou un pas de côté
un des comment dire un des côtés
désastreux de la liste de 77 médicaments
dont nous avons parlé au début c'est
qu'elle mélange tout et qu'elle ne
fournit aucune piste concrète pour
expliquer pour réfléchir avec les
patients que les patients réfléchissent
avec leurs prescripteurs avec leur
pharmacien sur l'intérêt du médicament
dans leur situation
je ferme la parenthèse donc les
statistiques de prescrire une fois par
an récapitulatif nombre de médicaments
qui sont des régressions thérapeutique
quand on voit que depuis environ 2005 on
est passé de quelques uns parents à une
quinzaine environ il ya des fluctuations
bien entendu mais c'est de l'ordre d'une
quinzaine par an quand on regarde de
l'autre côté les sorties du marché pour
f1 désirable on en voit en général trois
ou quatre par an donc il est évident
qu'il en arrive plus qu'il n'en sort
donc il en rien il y en a de plus en
plus sur le marché donc je ne peux pas
en faire la scène la liste nominative
précise vous voyez ces dernières
semaines qu'on a beaucoup parlé du
buflomédil qui est sensé qui a été
annoncé comme retirer aujourd'hui 17
février donc un vasodilatateur qui
n'apportait rien de concret en termes
d'efficacité mais qu'ils étaient
dangereux du point de vue
cardiovasculaire et neurologiques
vous avez vu que nous avons beaucoup
parlé du nimésulide un
anti-inflammatoire qui n'apportent pas
de progrès par rapport aux autres
anti-inflammatoires me qui est toxique
pour le foie
vu que nous parlons de la pioglitazone
actos qui est un antidiabétique qui
n'apportent là non plus rien de concret
en tout cas rien qui soit démontrée en
prévention des complications du diabète
mais qui augmente le risque de cancer de
la vessie qui était une maladie grave
difficile à soigner
vous avez eu il y en a beaucoup je ne
vais pas prétendre refaire la liste donc
bien sûr il y a beaucoup de choses à
changer dans les conditions
d'autorisation de mise sur le marché et
de surveillance parce que sinon nous
avons d'autres médiator en vue c'est
évident en france et partout dans le
monde
j'ai encore une ou deux questions si je
vais essayer de les regrouper
est ce que quelqu'un qu'elle est plus
largement en fait quel est le rôle de la
presse médicale en matière de formation
et des médecins et quels moyens
permettrait selon vous de renforcer son
indépendance
estimez vous que la charte de la visite
médicale on en avait aussi parlé dans le
cas du vioxx est un outil efficace et
préconisez vous des mesures
complémentaires en la matière alors bien
sûr les les prescripteurs les
professionnels de santé en général ça ne
concerne pas que les médecins c'est même
chose pour pharmaciens infirmiers etc
ils ont bien sûr besoin d'une
information indépendante sur les
thérapeutiques en général et donc les
médicaments puisque nous parlons
médicaments alors la presse biomédicale
on va dire est majoritairement très
majoritairement financée par les firmes
pharmaceutiques sous forme de publicité
ou d'insertion d'articles alors à partir
de là c'est mal parti puisque il est
vraiment ce sont des supports sous
influence pour la plupart pas tous
prescrire et est financé exclusivement
par les abonnés il n'y a aucune
publicité aucune subvention
il n'ya pas d'actionnaire puisque
l'éditeur est une association à but non
lucratif selon la loi 1901
donc on peut tout à fait
avoir effectivement une presse
indépendante des firmes de santé est
financé par les abonnés en l'occurrence
à prescrire principalement des
professionnels de santé pas
exclusivement bien entendu c'est ouvert
à tout puisque comme il n'ya pas de
publicité pour professionnels de santé
tout le monde peut s'abonner il ya
aucune fin c'est totalement libre bien
entendu alors cette revue paraît plus
cher à l'abonnement effectivement que
les concurrents qui sont financés par
les sciences pharmaceutiques puisque les
tarifs des autres d autres supports sont
diminuées par la publicité
voilà tout alors ça n'a rien de spécial
à la france la situation est la même
dans tous les pays et dans tous les pays
il y à au moins une équipe indépendante
des firmes pharmaceutiques qui diffuse
une information indépendante fiable
critique sur les médicaments et la
plupart de ces équipes sont regroupées
au sein d'un réseau international dont
fait partie prescrit alors visite
médicale à notre sens il n'y a pas
d'informations fiables attendre des
visiteurs médicaux
puisque les pauvres ils sont rémunérés
par une firme pharmaceutique ou un
prestataire de services est jugé sur les
chiffres de vente
donc ils sont directement intéressés ou
vente des médicaments du moment qu'ils
doivent promouvoir les chartes et autres
encadrement ne changeront rien à ce
problème
c'est là aussi c'est comment dire le mal
est à la racine sy lui dire c'est le
problème du financement même et du
critère de performance de jugement de
performance de ces de cette profession
donc à notre avis il est inutile de
passer du temps à chercher à faire une
charte ou à améliorer la question est
simplement la solution est simplement
que les médecins dans l'occurrence les
pharmaciens aussi parce qu'il ya des
délégués pharmaceutique réalisent qu'ils
n'ont pas d'informations fiables à
attendre de la visite médicale et donc
qu'il cesse comme vous qu'il cesse de
recevoir les visiteurs médicaux ou
pharmaceutiques comme d'ailleurs de plus
en plus le fond alors bien sûr le média
humain c'est-à-dire un visiteur un
délégué qui vient apporter une
information sur médicaments aux
professionnels de santé ça c'est une
bonne chose
il y à des pays et il ya eu quelques
expériences françaises où effectivement
le visiteur n'était pas rémunérée par la
firme pharmaceutique mais par une
instance un organisme d'intérêt public
et où l'information ne visait pas à
propos
voir les ventes mais à promouvoir la
qualité de la prescription ou des choix
thérapeutiques et bah ça c'est un outil
efficace de même que la presse est un
outil efficace d'information c'est un
moyen complémentaire
mais en france je m'excuse mais vous
faites référence à kehl à quel exemple
parce que en france à ma connaissance il
existe bien sûr les délégués de
l'assurance maladie avec qui sont
rémunérés par l'assurance maladie
oui il n'existe pas de visiteurs
médicaux qu'ils soient rémunérées par
une instance disant indépendante comptes
de la sécurité sociale et des
laboratoires
vous avez raison effectivement il n'ya
pas de visiteurs prescrit en particulier
oui basé en belgique
il y à un réseau d'alleurs de visiteurs
indépendant de l'assurance maladie à ma
connaissance
oui non je ne connais pas le détail de
financement mais je crois que mon style
assurance maladie y contribuer je ne
pense que ça n'est pas majoritaire
d'accord mais justement votre avis sur
les dames qu'est ce que c'est que vous
avez un avis sur les les délégations
ceux de l'assurance maladie qui vont
comme les visiteurs médicaux qui
rencontre les médecins est-ce que vous
êtes favorable ou est-ce que vous êtes
critique par rapport à cette ba c'est
déjà bien mieux que d'être financée par
la firme pharmaceutique
cela dit il faut faire attention
l'assurance maladie a aussi une
performance économique en quelque sorte
à assurer
donc il faut prendre garde et c'est pour
ça que le modèle économique choisi par
prescrire et le financement par les
personnes intéressées donc
principalement les professionnels de
santé mais bien sûr tous les patients
peuvent s'abonner aussi pour nous c'est
le modèle économique qui permet la
moindre dépendance ou la plus grande
indépendance
on peut pas être indépendant de tous
sinon on n'est plus dans le monde vivent
bon donc nous sommes dépendants
prescrire est dépendant de ces trente
mille et quelques abonnés c'est exact
mais nous ne sommes pas dépendants de
l'assurance maladie
l'idée choix des dirigeants de
l'assurance maladie ni du gouvernement
ni des firmes et c'est pour nous c'est
la meilleure ou la moins mauvaise
solution
d'accord est-ce que les mauvais et ils
financement et niveau de financement
pardon de l'afssaps vous paraît
aujourd'hui satisfaisant et kehl
ur préconisez vous concrètement en
termes de gouvernance c'est vrai qu'on
critique on critique on critique mais
quelles mesures concrètes pour améliorer
le système de gouvernance au delà de la
fois avec la problématique du
financement et au delà de la
problématique du financement alors à
notre avis bien entendu ne serait ce que
symboliquement et pour les esprits il y
a tout intérêt à ce que le financement
d'une agence du médicament soit
indépendant des firmes le fait qu'il y
ait le moindre lien avec les redevances
les frais de dossier là enfin les
redevances comme ça s'appelle évidemment
c'est néfaste
même si on peut dire qu'il y à des
écrans etc enfin à notre avis il doit y
avoir aucun rapport aucun rapport
financier entre les siennes --l'agence
bien c'est une première chose cela dit
pour nous à prescrire nous n'avons pas
beaucoup critiqué le financement de
l'afssaps
si il est il est choquant que ce soit
lié au financement fin ou redevances
bien entendu mais pour le plus grave est
le le fait que à quel point les firmes
et les personnes je veux dire pas les
décisions les décisions les décisions
des agents sont sous influence des
firmes nous avons créé en 2005 et ça
fait réagir le directeur de l'époque
effectivement nous nous posions la
question à voir les actes des décisions
prises nous avons nous poser la question
est ce que la simple c'était d'abord au
service des firmes pharmaceutiques au
service des patients puisque trop
souvent dans les décisions finalement
prise par l'afssaps ou proposée par la
france
c'est l'intérêt des firmes l'intérêt
économique défiant pharmaceutique qui
passe avant alors avant l'intérêt des
patients et on le voit avec médiator est
par exemple on a vu à quel point ce trop
souvent trop souvent l'afssaps est
sensible à l'argumentation des firmes et
reconnaît à celle qu'il faudrait
d'autres études pour prouver que le
médicament est dangereux etc
et pendant ce temps là les mais les
personnes restent exposés les effets
indésirables indésirables survienne le
nombre de victimes augmente mais les
ventes continuent bien alors
à ce phénomène le film doit sûrement
plusieurs cause le financement est sans
doute un facteur pour nous il n'est pas
déterminant il y as sans doute un état
d'esprit général
et je ne sais pas comment ça se traduit
en gouvernance mais pour nous il ya un
état d'esprit que la mission des
décideurs des personnes qui travaillent
à la saps est d'abord la protection des
personnes des patients de la population
il n'est pas la régulation du marché et
n'est pas les négociations avec les
firmes pharmaceutiques et n'est pas de
rendre service aux firmes
pharmaceutiques c'est-à-dire d'octroyer
là et même en allant un peu plus vite ou
de retarder les retraits du marché
pour nous c'est une question d'état
d'esprit la mission des agences du
médicament doit est la protection en
premier des patients et c'est d'autant
plus choquant quand on voit médiator est
tout ce qui si tout ce qui est révélé à
cette occasion quand on se souvient que
donc là le nom actuel de l' agence du
médicament et agence française de
sécurité sanitaire des produits de santé
mais où est la sécurité sanitaire quand
on l'est médiator pendant des années sur
le marché bien alors sans doute la
présence le recours à de nombreux
experts qui ont des liens d'intérêt avec
l'industrie pharmaceutique est aussi un
facteur décisif dans ses comportements
qui donnent trop l'intérêt la priorité
aux firmes plutôt qu'aux patients qu'à
la population
ça revient ça recoupe le problème du
financement de la recherche clinique
tant que la recherche clinique et
financé largement par les firmes
pharmaceutiques
il est évident que les siens
pharmaceutiques sont conduites à
contacter et à utiliser les services de
nombreux cliniciens de nombreux
spécialistes de nombreux connaisseurs de
telle ou telle maladie et il se créé le
cercle vicieux que de plus en plus de
cliniciens de spécialistes d'experts
comme on dit de tel ou tel problème de
santé sont des liens d'intérêt avec les
firmes pharmaceutiques et on en vient à
dire ne peut pas en trouver d'autres
alors d'abord c'est faux on en trouve
d'autres mais c'est vrai qu'il y en a
beaucoup et de plus en plus tant qu'on
laisse l'essentiel de la recherche
clinique financé par les firmes
pharmaceutiques
alors ça c'est une mesure changer cela
nécessite sûrement beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de transferts d'argent beaucoup
de changements de mécanismes mais pour
nous il est indispensable de s'y
attaquer le rapporteur est terminée là
d'autres questions pour peu qu'ils aient
la demande est évident aussi la non pas
je peux pas leur monsieur tulle et vous
avez vous nous avez indiqué monsieur que
vous aviez trente mille abonnements peu
ou prou ce chiffre faible par rapport au
nombre de prescripteurs possible par
quels autres moyens l'alertent est elle
donnée aux praticiens au pharmacien ou
au corps médical en général parce qu'il
ya la sortie du médicament mais il ya
toute cette période intermédiaire est
floue à l'intérieur de laquelle vous
avez joué un rôle mais comment ce rôle
peut-il être démultipliée alors il ya
effectivement un peu plus de 30 mille
abonnés à prescrire actuellement c'est à
dire environ un quart des médecins
généralistes français et environ 5 à
6000 pharmaciens pour eux environ 20000
officines
je ne compte pas les hôpitaux
alors effectivement c'est une minorité
dans chaque profession c'est une
minorité seulement qui est abonné à
prescrire cette minorité en train
d'augmenter parce que bien entendu
médiator ouvre les yeux à beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes professionnels ou
non réaliste qu'une grande partie de
l'information du médicament et soul
influence est entre les mains des firmes
pharmaceutiques directement on a parlé
de la visite médicale de la presse dès
qu'on n'a pas parlé des congrès mais on
aurait pu et puis l'évaluation même des
médicaments
alors d'où peut venir par ailleurs l'
alerte alors elle devrait venir à notre
avis les agences du médicament encore
une fois les agences du médicament
devrait être à notre avis en priorité au
service de la protection de la santé des
personnes en priorité
alors bien sûr les agences du médicament
diffuse une certaine information
de ce point de vue là on peut dire que
les choses ont progressé depuis les
années 80 par exemple 90 sur par exemple
sur le site de l'agencé européenne des
médicaments pour les médicaments dont
elle a conseillé l'autorisation il y a
des rapports d'évaluation
ce sont des choses qu'on ne connaissait
pas ou guère avant enfin durant les
années 80-90 en partie que les années 70
je n'en parle pas alors il ya donc de
petits progrès de ce point de vue là
mais ils sont très lents et il faut bien
sûr les encourager beaucoup à notre avis
donc l'information elle devrait venir
beaucoup plus de l' agence du médicament
à saab sous ou autres quel que soit le
pays
on a aussi les avis de la transmission
et les avis de la commission de la
transparence qui sont intéressants qui
sont en ligne on peut critiquer parfois
la lenteur de la mise en ligne à des
fois des délais qui nous paraissent
curieux malgré tout et on peut bien sûr
avoir donc doit bien sûr avoir en tête
que là aussi il y à des conflits
d'intérêts qui sont à l'oeuvre
il y aussi de l' influence par les
firmes pharmaceutiques malgré tout c'est
déjà une information tout de même bien
plus intéressante que ce qu'apporte le
visiteur médical ou la publicité ou les
relais d'opinion plus ou moins
clairement financées par l'industrie
pharmaceutique
ensuite bien entendu je large et j'ai
bien entendu un lien d'intérêt tout le
monde peut s'abonner à prescrire il n'y
a aucune interdiction bien entendu il y
a aussi d'autres sources d'information
hors de france il y a des périodiques ou
des sites d'information belge par
exemple francophones qui apporte une
information intéressante
et puis ici on fait l'effort de
s'intéresser à la langue anglaise et de
déchiffrer au moins l'anglais et
biomédicale qui n'est pas shakespeare on
peut avoir beaucoup d'informations via
sentent bien entendu le plus souvent
cette information est payante
ça c'est évident qu'à notre avis
l'information de qualité et payantes et
n'est pas gratuite merci une autre
question oui monsieur domaine je sais
que je reviens moi je voulais savoir ce
qu il ya à peu près 50 % des
prescriptions médicamenteuses qui sont
données qui sont pour le mica mahorais
mais ce que presque la vôtre revue
analyse aussi de très près cette somme
de médicaments importants qui qui sont
sûrs ils sont délivrés ou alors le
statut de médicament c'est le statut le
plus sûr ou le moins mauvais comme on
veut des produits de santé
il est clair que le statut de médicament
avec autorisation de mise en marché
c'est mieux que le statut de compléments
alimentaires ou de dispositif médical
c'est pour ça que c'est aussi une des
raisons pour lesquelles il faut être
exigeant et à notre avis très exigeant
sur l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
du médicament parce qu'encore une fois
un médicament essentiel munis d'une
autorisation de mission de marché c'est
le maximum de garanties de qualité de
vin de qualité de l'outil thérapeutique
bien alors c'est pour ça que prescrire
mais la priorité de ses moyens en
matière d'analysé de nouveaux
médicaments sur les médicaments avec
autorisation de l'émission marchait bien
alors cela dit bien entendu il faut pas
confondre la mm et l'état de la science
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché est
une autorisation
en réponse à la demande d'une firme
pharmaceutique qui souhaitent avoir une
part de marché dans telles situations
cliniques tels problèmes de santé pour
tel type de patients pour tel médicament
at-elle dosage et dentelles et elle
était de conditions c'est très étroit
c'est très étroit par rapport à
l'ensemble des problèmes de santé qui
lie à traiter bien donc c'est logique
qu'il y à des prescriptions hors amm
même alors le problème est de savoir si
ces prescriptions aura mêmes sont bien
conformes aux données de la science
c'est la difficulté alors prescrire
n'étudie pas méthodiquement l'ensemble
des prescriptions aura mêmes c'est un
chant difficile à analyser est immense
par contre prescrire dans une autre
rubrique rayon des nouveautés mais la
rubrique stratégie en l'occurrence
analyse et compare les choix
thérapeutiques non pas par spécialités
pharmaceutiques non pas du point de vue
réglementaire mais du point de vue de
l'évaluation comparative de la balance
bénéfices risques et des divers
traitements face à tel ou tel problème
de santé
et si nous constatons que pour tel
problème les données montrent que la
meilleure solution est tel médicament et
que en france il n'est pas autorisé dans
cette situation et bien nous le disons
et nous incitons les abonnés à examiner
ce choix de prêt --probablement à faire
ce choix pour certains patients
alors bien sûr nous incitons donc
parfois à prescrire aura humaine ce
n'est pas souvent parce que souvent la
prescription aura mêmes ne correspond
pas à une bonne évaluation comparative
de la balance bénéfice risque et du
progrès par rapport aux autres
médicaments aux autres traitements mais
cela peut arriver bien sûr madame blanc
2e jeu rapidement quelles sont les
ressources humaines les méthodes de
l'équipe de prescrits en résumé alors
les ressources humaines sont affichées
de façon assez transparente en page 2 de
couverture c'est l'ours de la revue
prescrire et donc en résumé on peut dire
que l'équipe compte une centaine de
personnes beaucoup à temps partiel et
donc il y a environ les kids 20 oui les
environs 70 équivalents temps plein si
on peut parler comme cela alors les
méthodes et bien nous cherchons à voir
le minimum de dépendance financière et
donc intellectuelle donc j'ai parlé tout
à l'heure de l'abonnement
ensuite il y a une méthode de travail
très collective
il y a bien sûr que tous les rédacteurs
et toutes les personnes ont l'engagement
de ne pas avoir de liens d'intérêt avec
les firmes pharmaceutiques domaine de la
santé plus généralement ça je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure
il y a ensuite surtout donc une méthode
de travail très collective que je vais
peut-être pas passé trop de temps à
détailler mais comment dire enfin il y
avait deux choses excusez-moi méthode
collectives c'est-à-dire que les
articles sont signés prescrire et non
pas nominativement par tel ou tel
rédacteurs et c'est la réalité il y a
bien sûr un rédacteur principal à chaque
texte mais il est très tôt entouré par
une équipe un petit groupe qui fait la
programmation de des rubriques un petit
groupe qui décide de la des priorités
que comment les priorités du moment dans
telle ou telle rubrique pour tel ou tel
genre de médicament tel jeu tel ou tel
genre de traitement etc et aussi les
priorités pour tel ou tel rédacteurs et
une fois qu'on a décidé de mettre en
route un texte un article sur tel
problème précisément et bien
effectivement nous recherchons un
rédacteur compétent pour le faire très
bien il est d'accord ça s'insère dans
son emploi du temps
on y va tout de suite et constituer une
équipe avec un rédacteur référent qui
sera son premier lecteur avec le
responsable de rubrique qui sera la
première personne qui va après le
travail du couple on va dire du binôme
rédacteurs rédacteurs référent qui va
passer l'ensemble il aussi en revue
l'ensemble de la documentation
rassemblée la méthode dont cette
documentation étaient rassemblées dont
elle était exploité la façon des jeux
les premiers échanges les premiers
textes la concordance entre la version
du texte qui est retenue par le binôme
rédacteur principal rédacteur référent
et la concordance de ces de ce texte
avec l'ensemble des références qui ont
été retenus et puis ce responsable de
rubrique va soumettre ce texte à un
comité de lecture qui comporte vingt ou
trente personnes environ
parfois un peu moins parfois un peu plus
ça dépend du sujet de l'ampleur du texte
et des personnes quelques unes à
l'intérieur de prescrire mais
principalement à l'extérieur de
prescrire pour croiser beaucoup de
points de vue et donc danser parmi ces
électeurs nous sollicitons des naïfs des
experts des généralistes et spécialistes
des médecins des pharmaciens qui
travaillent en ville qui travaille à
l'hôpital etc pour recouper beaucoup de
points de vue
ensuite le texte est de nouveau confier
l'ensemble du dossier de nouveau confiée
au rédacteur principal qui est chargé
d'examiner les contributions de ses
électeurs et il ne cherche pas en faire
une synthèse consensuelle pour faire
plaisir à tout le monde
il cherche comme depuis le début à faire
un texte qui soit réellement objectifs
fiable informatif donc quand par exemple
un relecteur ne comprends pas ce que
nous avons dit ou n'est pas d'accord le
rédacteur cherche à améliorer la
formulation
si le relecteur dit qu'il n'est pas
d'accord nous avons oublié telles
références ou n'est pas d'accord avec
notre interprétation de telle ou telle
publication
là le rédacteur repart à la référence
d'origine réexamine et voici ou tâche de
voir en tout cas si c'est prescrire qui
a raison ou si c'est le rédac' de leurs
lecteurs qui a raison et c'est toujours
l'examen critique et toujours le souci
de contribuer à une information fiable
et non pas de faire un consensus bien
alors le coup de la suite du circuit et
que le responsable de rubrique va de
nouveau repasser en revue l'ensemble du
dossier y compris les contributions des
relecteurs et y compris la façon dont le
rédacteur a pris en compte ces
contributions
puis il ya ensuite le travail du
rédacteur adjoint qui va comparer ligne
à ligne chiffre à chiffres la véracité
des assertions du texte prescrire avec
les références retenues parce que à part
les éditoriaux tous les textes prescrire
sont référencés la bibliographie retenus
figurent en fin de texte
elle est tenu à disposition des abonnés
pendant cinq ans de façon à ce que
chacun puisse comparer ce qu'a dit
prescrire et si qu'il y avait dans
l'écrit le document écrit qui c'est qui
a servi de source donc il ya le travail
du rédacteur adjoint et de comparer le
texte prescrire et les données qui sont
dans le texte source
en proposant au responsable de rubrique
une reformulation ou une correction mais
sans la faire lui-même
encore une fois le responsable de
rubrique toujours pour croiser les
points de vue va lui-même regarder de
façon critique le travail de rédacteur
adjoint
bon je vais pas aller plus loin mais on
a fait le plus gros du parcours il ya
encore un petit parcours un peu
collectif donc
voilà travail collectif et puis j'ai
parlé documentation il ya bien sûr une
toujours une méthode de recherche
documentaire soit de veille documentaire
pour de petits textes d'actualité mais
de recherche documentaire méthodique
pour la plupart des textes est en tout
cas tous les dossiers approfondie en
particulier pour le rayon des nouveautés
dont nous parlons tout à l'heure et si
j'ai encore quelques instants je peux
dire que pour les nouveaux médicaments
nous interrogeons toujours
méthodiquement selon une méthode un
protocole qui évolue que nous adaptons
bien sûr mais les principes sont
toujours d'interroger la firme
pharmaceutique concernés parce que nous
estimons qu'elle est responsable d'une
information sur les produits qu'elle
vend nous interrogeons l' agence du
médicament car nous estimons qu'elle est
responsable de l'information du
médicament qu'elle a autorisé ou d'état
ou dont elle a recommandé l'autorisation
nous interrogeons la littérature
scientifique et nous interrogeons les
autres équipes indépendantes comme
prescrire tout autour du monde et en
particulier celle du réseau yes db jarir
cela merci je pense que j'avais obtenu
la satisfaction au delà de ce que vous
espériez madame rouzier
appuyez sur le à côté ça marche
vous avez dit que en 1997 vous aviez
analysé le bnd flux oreilles tu sais que
vous aviez démontré qu'il n'y avait
aucune preuve d'efficacité sur le pour
le cholestérol ou et pour le diabète est
ce que vous avez fait des gros titres
dans votre revue pour alerter puisque
tous les médecins ou les pharmaciens
tous les gens qui lisent votre revue est
ce qu'ils ont pu être alertés à ce
moment là est ce qu'il ya eu des
retombées des firmes pharmaceutiques
disant que que vous gâcher le travail ou
que je ne sais quoi et et comment votre
revue justement est elle ressentie par
par ces firmes est aussi par tous les
organismes que je vais appeler nationaux
qui sont chargés du contrôle de la
vigilance etc
vous devez pas être très bien vue se
défend partout et puis autre question
est ce que votre revue et est accessible
aux béotiens parce qu est-ce que quand
on n'y connaît rien en médecine ou en
pharmacie est ce qu'on peut comprendre
suivent et profiter des choses qui vous
publiez sur la rumeur sur la revue
jusqu'au bts que lé 30 mille abonnements
à prescrire sont payants et quelle est
l'ampleur de la diffusion gratte ça je
peux vous dire que c'est payant
je paye et bravo je reçois beaucoup de
revues médicales sans y être abonné non
mais je j'apporte un témoignage à traire
je peux
vous m'en donnez à l'autorisation madame
le rapporteur eliès je vous en remercie
voilà mais la parole monsieur question
je vais essayer alors gros titres non
nous n'avons pas fait de gros titres
particulièrement sur ce médicament les
articles le kit de mémoire faisait trois
pages avec un titre comme pour les
autres articles du numéro de cette
catégorie
rétrospectivement bien sûr on peut le
regretter et d'un autre côté là
aujourd'hui nous sommes concentrés sur
médiator mais nous avons bien vu que
c'est un révélateur nous avons entendu
tout à l'heure que il ya beaucoup de
problèmes qui se posent et donc si nous
faisons que des gros titres sur tout ça
ça va ça n'aura pas l'effet banques donc
nous importe là nous apportons à
l'information et nous tâchons de titres
et de façon proportionnée à l'ampleur du
texte et ne faisons pas de nous
cherchons pas à faire de sensationnel là
dessus bien
en plus à l'époque il n'y avait pas
encore de preuves concrètes des effets
indésirables pour nous ce qui suffisait
à ne pas utiliser ce médicament
il ya le retirer du marché c'était le
fait que pas d'efficacité concrètes et
de très forts doutes sur ces effets
indésirables puisque c'est un couffin et
nous paraissait qu'il n'y avait pas lieu
d'attendre d'avoir des victimes
bon voilà tout je veux dire qu'à
l'époque là je n'ai pas le numéro avec
moi mais à l'époque il y avait
probablement dans la rubrique vigilance
qui consacrait qui est centrée sur les
effets indésirables des médicaments des
choses plus plus plus urgente encore que
ce dossier là quatre patients
l'essai laisser que vous avez publié
c'était était pas les comptes-rendus les
analystes c'était cinq patients sur 34
oui c'était il y avait bien entendu déjà
très peu d'informations sûres sur les
effets indésirables de ce médicament
mais bon on va pas il faut que répondre
à d'autres questions là alors je vais
perdre le fil je pense alors est-ce que
prescrire est accessible prescrire est
accessible est accessible sur abonnement
voilà alors effectivement il n'est pas à
la gare on peut pas s'abonner à la gare
bon ni au kiosque
pourquoi je vous l'aï dit tout à l'heure
c'est le seul mais le seul modèle
économique qui jusqu'à présent a paru
fiable à l'équipe et qui de fait est
efficace puisque prescrire est né à la
fin des années quatre à la fin des
années 70 grâce à une subvention du
ministère de la santé qui a été bien
utile pendant une dizaine d'années mais
l'équipe avait bien en tête de
d'organiser le sevrage de cette
subvention est d'obtenir un financement
par les abonnés et ce qui a été
difficile et ce qui est souvent
difficile mais fonctionne bien depuis
lors donc c'est réellement faisable
possible tout le monde est rémunéré à
prescrire il ya bien entendu
l'envié de bien faire un certain
militantisme c'est certain mais et tout
le monde est rémunéré correctement gains
alors accessible du point de vue du
texte alors c'est vrai que le
l'essentiel des abonnés en nombre sont
effectivement des professionnels de
santé et les rédacteurs sont
principalement des professionnels de
santé donc c'est vrai qu'il y a un
certain pré requis de culture médicale
bon c'est exact cela dit les
professionnels de santé ne sont pas
tombés dans la culture médicale quand
ils étaient petits ils ont appris comme
tout le monde et j'ai de l'expérience je
crois montre que quand on est quand on
s'intéresse à un sujet il faut se
cultiver un petit peu c'est pas très
long et ensuite les textes prescrire
tâche d'être écrit de façon aussi
intelligible que nous pouvons alors
ensuite destination directe du grand
public
pour l'instant nous ne savons pas le
faire mais nous n'avons pas non plus
prétention aucune prétention avoir le
monopole de l'information en ce moment
là depuis quelques semaines nous sommes
enchantés de voir beaucoup de
journalistes qui réalise l'ampleur du
problème de l'information sur le
médicament qui réalise que signifie pas
que le médicament soit autorisée pour
que tout aille bien qu'il ya au
contraire beaucoup de problèmes et donc
beaucoup de journalistes de journalistes
utilisent prescrire pour leurs textes et
va nous trouvons ça magnifique de la
même façon que madame frachon médecin
spécialiste lisait prescrire il ya bien
raconté qu'en lisant prescrire elle a
réalisé que il y avait peut-être bien du
benfluorex à l'origine de tels et tels
malades dont elle constatait les
problèmes
cardio pulmonaire et ont ensuite enfin
vous savez la suite donc je ne vais pas
revenir là dessus
donc voilà prescrire porte une
information fiable pour tout le monde
le financement c'est par l'abonnement
est pas en kiosque voilà tout oui le
mécanisme gratuitement des diffusions
gratuites non il n'y a pas de diffusion
gratuite de prescrire il ya des échanges
avec d'autres revues avec d'autres
périodiques
alors on peut dire que c'est gratuit
c'est un échantillon du troc mais ces
quelques centaines d'exemplaires
l'abonnement oui alors si vous reporter
j'apportais elle réponse à un mot
d'amour dit en ce qui concerne la
réputation que vous avez auprès des
firmes
oui monsieur à l'âge où vous considère
comme une milice privée
peut-être oui enfin bon c'est le terme
qui l'employait revient alors
effectivement c'est privé ça c'est sûr
mais lis je ne crois pas en tout cas je
suis désormais jeu alors ce qui est
certain c'est que là aussi il faut bien
faire attention le jusqu'à présent j'ai
parlé les firmes les médicaments bon
bien entendu c'est comme les humains il
ya beaucoup de variété les firmes
pharmaceutiques
il ne faut pas les considérer forcément
toutes dans le même sac
par exemple chaque année au mois de
janvier
prescrire organise la pilule d'or et
organise trois palmarès des nouveaux
médicaments de l'information transmise
par les firmes pharmaceutiques à
prescrire et du conditionnement des
médicaments examinés par prescrire dans
l'année qui a précédé et donc nous
récompensons nous récompensons les
sciences pharmaceutiques qui à notre
avis ont bien travaillé et bien les
représentants des firmes pharmaceutiques
sont heureux de venir à cette
manifestation et en particulier je ne
sais pas si si quelques personnes
étaient là la pilule d'or mais je vous
promets je vous promets les journalistes
étaient là ont pu voir pu constater que
oui
les représentants des firmes
pharmaceutiques
nominé par prescrire sont venus à notre
invitation et sont venus chercher un
diplôme qui reconnaissait lucky 7 où ça
ou prescrire saluer le bon travail
prescrire n'est pas anti fiant
pharmaceutique prescrire et pour les
ceux qui font le bon
travail qui permettent de mieux soigner
quand une firme pharmaceutique met sur
le marché un médicament qui apportent un
progrès thérapeutique nous le saluons
mais quand une fille en pharmaceutique
met sur le marché un médicament qui est
une régression thérapeutique
nous ne savions pas la firme bien je
vais avant de terminer vous poser de
questions alors l'une concernant
d'expertisé l'autre concernant le
circuit du médicament
alors les expertises est-ce qu'il vous
semble que la présence d'experts ayant
lien d'intérêt dans les commissions de
l'afssaps
bien que ces liens d'intérêts fassent
l'objet de la transparence est
compatible avec la mission qui leur est
dévolue
c'est à dire est-ce qu'on peut être en
même temps que conseiller des firmes est
aussi conseillé de des pouvoirs publics
enfin parler au nom de l'état c'est la
première question
peut-être que vous voulez vous pouvez
répondre à la première et on reviendra
ensuite à la seconde il y a plusieurs
études ou des médecins ont été
interrogés sur l' influence de la visite
médicale ou des étudiantes étaient
médecins comme des étudiants est souvent
la réponse majoritaire et que à huy les
autres ils sont influencés par la visite
médicale mais moi non je ne suis moi je
sais garder mon esprit critique
le problème est que la plupart dit cela
et l'expérience montre que oui l'avis
médical est efficace pour augmenter les
ventes auprès des prescripteurs auprès
des étudiants auprès des médecins
installés et c'est alors notre avis bien
sûr il faut que les experts n'est pas de
liens d'intérêt avec les firmes
pharmaceutiques
c'est la seule solution pour que il
n'est pas de conflit d'intérêts
le conflit se résout quand il n'ya pas
de liens d'intérêt avec les firmes
pharmaceutiques et c'est ça qu'il faut
exiger bien entendu la deuxième question
concerne le circuit du médicament
il est effectivement complexe vous le
savez il ya donc l'afssaps
autorisation ni sur le marché ensuite
l'examen par la chasse ensuite la
fixation du prix c'est l'assurance
maladie qui fixe le le taux de
remboursement est ce que est ce que vous
pensez que il y à des réformes à faire
est en quel sens en particulier quelle
place doit tenir dans ce système la
pharmacovigilance et qu'actuellement
elle et elle est complètement tributaire
de la commission d'un mm ce qu'il faut
lui donner plus d'indépendance comment
est-ce qu'il faut réunir tout ce qui
concerne le médicament dans une même
structure
est-ce que la fixation du prix doit être
doit être toujours de la responsabilité
du saps ou est-ce qu'on doit envisager
d'autres systèmes
je sais pas si vous pouvez répondre à
toutes ces questions mais enfin celles
pour lesquelles vous pouvez répondre je
serais très heureux que vous puissiez
apporter des réponses
oui on vient de vous apporter une
réponse à une question
allez un bon c'est parfait
la dissolution a eu lieu voilà je vous
en prie allez-y monsieur alors sûrement
pas possible de répondre en quelques
instants à tout cela c'est complexe
puisqu'on parle pharmacovigilance
beaucoup avec médiator il est important
pour nous que effectivement les moyens
existent les moyens financiers et
humains de la pharmacovigilance en
france soit largement augmenté et que
les décisions ou les positions
pardon il faut qu'il faut qu'un autre
avis donc pardon excusez moi
pharmacovigilance bien sûr en france
comme dans les autres pays elle est sous
développé alors il faut bien entendu la
développer beaucoup avec de l'argent et
des moyens humains que les travaux de
pharmacovigilance soit valorisée
probablement que les travaux de
pharmacovigilance soit encore plus
valorisé que les travaux faits en
collaboration avec les firmes bien bien
sûr je parle de pharmacovigilance public
bien entendu un financement public
exclusivement bien et il faut bien sûr
que les préconisations des instances de
pharmacovigilance et autant de poids que
les préconisations des commissions die
même c'est à dire que les prix les
préconisations qui vise au retrait du
marché ou à la restriction de
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
mais en général le plus efficace et le
retrait est pas pas les demi-mesures
autour de l'autorisation
il faut que ces préconisations et autant
de poids auprès des décideurs que l'avis
de la commission d'un mêmes il faut donc
changer la situation actuelle où
toujours la commission de
pharmacovigilance doit en référer
effectivement à la commission d'harry
même il faut changer ça il faut
équilibrer il faut équilibrer cela
équilibre c'est sans doute un mot-clé
aussi de du cap qu'il faut fans de
nouveau système qu'il faut mettre en
place il faut bien davantage équilibrer
les rapports de force
actuellement les firmes pharmaceutiques
sont omniprésents dans le système et le
rapport de forces est totalement
déséquilibré tout à l'heure vous me
demande ma demande et les moyens de l'
agence du médicament alors grosso modo
grosso modo le budget de fonctionnement
de l' agence du médicament c'est l'ordre
de 100 millions d'euros si j'ai bien
compris une parents et bien et on voit
pour n'aller très court on voit que le
chiffre d'affaires de la firme servier
c'est de l'ordre de 3 milliards et c'est
une firme
et ce n'est pas la principale française
bien c'est pas la première
même si elle est bien placée donc il ya
une énorme disproportion de moyens et
les sciences pharmaceutiques sont donc
omniprésente elle finance la recherche
clinique
elle finance bon nombre d'experts elles
financent une bonne partie de la
formation des professionnels de santé
par exemple de la presse ou de
l'enseignement post-universitaire
commander ou la formation médicale
continue
elles financent une bonne partie des
associations de patients
elles sont omniprésentes
il faut rééquilibrer les rapports entre
laisser entre les acteurs de la santé
il faut remettre les firmes
pharmaceutiques à leur place oui je vous
en prie vous remercie monsieur le
président il refuse et moi mais j'étais
obligé de sortir un moment donc je
n'avais pas vu vous aviez distribuer des
questions sur mes notions de oui oui
mais vous avez eu votre question dont
vous pouvez la pause et non merci
monsieur tout ça j'ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention de ce que vous avez
dit j'ai pris assez de plaisir à vous
entendre
j'ai moi une petite question qui va plus
tel vous sembler un peu perfide mais je
voudrais quand même vous la posez votre
revue depuis 40 ans donc fait des isles
de médicaments et est-ce qu'elle s'est
trompée parfois dans ses analyses
est ce que quand vous êtes trompés vous
en avez informer vos lecteurs de ces
erreurs que vous avez pu faire et
j'espère que nous avons informé pardon
alors il y a de toute façon il y a de
toute façon il ya deux rubriques
régulières une qui s'appelle précision
correction ou nous corrigeons les
coquilles ou les erreurs effectivement
factuelle que nous avons commises et il
y en a quelques-unes chaque mois par
beaucoup bien entendu avec notre système
et quelques unes il ya de leur part une
aubry qui s'appelle prescrire en
question qui à la fin de l'heure de la
rubrique et où nous publions en
particulier toutes les contestations
écrite que nous adresser firmes
pharmaceutiques donc nous publions la
contestation de la fia et nos arguments
de même que nous avons publié par
exemple en 2005
la réponse enfin la réponse la lettre
que nous avez adressé le directeur de
l'afssaps qui trouvaient que nous étions
nous allions beaucoup trop loin au sujet
du benfluorex du dextropropoxyphène etc
alors nous avons publié sa lettre est
notre réponse aussi bien alors est ce
que nous avons est ce que nous nous
sommes trompés lourdement sur
l'appréciation de tel ou tel médicament
sincèrement je ne crois pas que nous
soyons trompait souvent nous avons fait
marche arrière sur un médicament
orphelin la galerie d'as dans la maladie
de fabry je prends
si je me suis trompé faudra corriger
voilà au vu des données accessibles
à l'époque nous avons trouvé que ce
médicament apporter vraiment beaucoup et
puis ensuite avec l'apparition d'autres
données nous avons vu que le progrès
était bien moindre que ce que nous
avions cru nous avons publié une
réanalyse avec plus de recul de
l'ensemble du dossier
et tout le monde peut le constater nous
avions pris mais ce médicament dans
notre palmarès annuel et la correction
figure désormais dans chaque palmarès
je crois que nous ne sommes nous ne nous
sommes pas souvent trompés
grâce à cette méthode de travail et
grâce au fait que nous avons toujours en
tête l'intérêt premier des patients nous
n'avons pas d'autres a priori nous ne
sommes pas profit renoue contre anti
firme nous ne sommes pas pro servier ou
anti sanofi ce n'est pas notre problème
nous cherchons à informer les
professionnels de santé pour soigner
mieux dans l'intérêt premier des
patients le rapporteur la question de
monsieur lemay d'un moment vous avez dit
oui la balance bénéfices risques est
faite aussi pour que le patient ait le
choix
j'ai par exemple je suis
maniaco-dépressif où j'ai une
polyarthrite aiguë et je n'arrive pas à
m'en sortir
bien évidemment à chaque fois qu'un
médicament sort je vais essayer de
tenter le coup parce que c'est tellement
insupportable qu'il faut que j'ai vu je
mets ma souffrance puissent être allégée
alors le patient souvent il a envie il a
une prescription
il croit on croit pas à la prescription
du médecin il ait envie de faire son
choix
il modifie quelquefois lui-même son
traitement il ya quelque chose là de qui
est de l'or à la fois de l'indécision
mais pas mais qui veut mais parce que le
patient il ne sait pas très bien où
aller alors le choix de patients il peut
faire son choix mais il est obligé au
site ce guide est aussi avec ce que va
lui dire le médecin et avec a peut-être
nouveau médicament qui va sortir qui
aura peut-être un effet à des rizières
bhl mais qui va peut-être le soulager
bien sûr mais il ya beaucoup qui sont
que dans ces situations là bien sûr
c'est très difficile c'est travail
durable continue la sortie du prozac il
ya quelques années c'était merveilleux
tapis on s'aperçoit que le prozac eux va
créer des tendances suicidaires bon mais
bien sûr bien sûr que pour beaucoup de
problèmes de santé la décision est
difficile à prendre
et bien sûr que les patients ont intérêt
à utiliser la prestation de services
d'un professionnel de santé du médecin
par exemple pour les médicaments sur
prescription bien entendu c'est pour ça
que prescrire tâche de diffuser une
information qui permettent de prendre
les décisions sur des bases solides
c'est à dire faire le tour des
connaissances savoir ce qu on sait ce
qu'on ne sait pas et puis décider
ensemble en conséquence bien sûr c'est
difficile ça ne peut pas se faire tout
seul enfin ça peut se faire tout seul
bien entendu mais pour que ça se fasse
au mieux il ya tout intérêt à utiliser
effectivement un professionnel de santé
à dialoguer avec lui a posé des
questions qu'est-ce qu'on gagne à
prendre ce médicament
que se passe-t-il si on ne le prend pas
est ce qu'il y à de meilleures solutions
qu'est ce qu'on risque à prendre ce
médicament etc
c'est pour ça qu'à notre avis il faut
être exigeant sur les conditions d'un
mêmes
il faut que les conditions l'allemagne
soit octroyé avec des éléments de
comparaison par rapport à ce qu'on a
déjà comme traitement parce que pour la
plupart des situations il y a déjà des
traitements disponibles qui ont leurs
limites bien entendu mais qui ont aussi
leurs qualités
donc il s'agit savoir si à l'occasion du
nouveau médicament
on ne risque pas plus pour moins
d'efficacité en l'expérience montre que
oui dans les nouveaux médicaments chaque
année il y à des médicaments qui sont
moins efficaces ou moins intéressants
que ceux qu'on a déjà ou qui sont plus
dangereux que ce qu'on a déjà 100
surcroît d'efficacité et je reviens pas
sur vioxx et compagnie c'est la même
problématique
donc bien sûr c'est très difficile alors
cela dit la l'ampleur du désastre la du
médiator qui vient après vioxx comme
vous avez dit et la cérivastatine plus
dia plus longtemps et puis le drs enfin
on va pas remonter trop loin
nous espérons à prescrire qu au moins
tous et toutes ces souffrances vont
servir tout de même à une meilleure
prise de conscience de la réalité
que beaucoup de nouveaux médicaments ne
sont pas meilleurs voire font pire que
les anciens que les médecins et les
professionnels de santé ont très grand
intérêt à utiliser des sources
indépendantes d'information sur le
médicament est pas que prescrire bref
nous espérons que toutes ces souffrances
dues au médiator vont permettre une
meilleure bien meilleure prise de
conscience et réflexion de l'ensemble de
la société
il ya bien sûr à réformer le système de
médicaments mais il ya toute une
meilleure pensez bien plus critique bien
plus lucide sur les médicaments surtout
en france où nous en consommons beaucoup
merci je pense que sauf si nos collègues
certains de nos collègues veulent poser
encore des questions nous allons lever
la séance sur vous remercions d'avoir
deux vous êtes prêté avec autant de
patients ceux à cet exercice quelquefois
difficile que de réponses aux questions
merci merci merci à vous le sujet mérite
beaucoup d'énergie nous nous ne manquons
pas nous allons donc terminer cette
série d'auditions ce matin par
l'audition de monsieur le professeur
pierre louis druet président du collège
de médecine générale que je remercie
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
je voudrais
lui signaler d'abord que le sceptre
séance cette audition est donc
retransmis par la télévision en feintes
et les bus public sénat et je voudrais
aussi lui demander conformément bien
entendu en application de l'article l
4113 tirs et 13 du code de la santé
publique de nous faire connaître
si vous en avez vos liens avec des
entreprises produisant ou exploitant les
produits de santé ou des organismes de
conseil intervenant sur ces produits
vous avez la parole
merci à monsieur le président filmé dans
le mécénat privé je vois c'est moi qui
vous remercie de m'inviter à 7.9 et
d'inviter la médecine vers allait
s'exprimer faire le sujet puisqu'elle
est quand même hautement concernés on va
dire je suis en du collège de la
médecine générale et j'ai pendant
étaient huit ans président du collège
national des généralistes enseignants
qui est une structure qui gère
l'enseignement de la médecine générale
et qui a contribué et participé à la
création de la discipline et du diplôme
d'études spécialisées et en tant que tel
je dit et cette présidence au mois de
novembre
on prend les années passent et gérer un
conflit des raids d'intérêts au sein
même du collège la fin du général s'en
faire puisque pour des activités de type
scientifique de recherche
il ya eu un certain nombre de
contributions et de partenariat avec le
nom de l'industrie pharmaceutique et
j'en citerai trois principalement parce
que certaines perdurent avec le collège
et donc je suis
pour autant qu'on s'est un peu confirmé
aidants membres du collège laboratoire
sanofi attentif pour la production de
d'un recueil bibliographiques médecine
générale qui est fait tous les ans et
qui recense les 100 articles
scientifiques les plus contributifs à
l'activité à la pratique de la médecine
générale
le laboratoire gfk dans le cadre de
formations qui touche à la fois au
secteur de la du patients dépressifs et
au secteur de la relation entre le
patient et le médecin
et puis le ramadan pierre fabre parce
que j'ai personnellement contribué et
piloter un travail de recherche sur les
anémies g chez la femme par carlo
fanfare et enfin tôt les carences en fer
font anémie chez les femmes source de
tableaux qui sont fera des syndromes
dépressifs fois défunt dans le masque
yannick weber et faites une recherche
internationale
voilà les trois conflits d'intérêts que
je souhaitais nommé oui c'est a lancé il
confie enfin ce sont des liens
d'intérêts des liens intéressants
cristallier le lien d'intérêt du conflit
d'intérêts enfin c'est des liens
d'intérêts personnels ou des liens
d'intérêt que votre collège à avec que
ce laboratoire
c'est ça le biais du collège d'accord il
a fondé contribution à cette activité
qu'en ce qui me concerne je n'ai aucun
intérêt personnel d'accord en tant qu
être rémunéré par ces structures
dans des activités frais ou ponctuels ou
pérennes est ce que ça vous ça pose pas
problème de 2,2 savoir 20 je mets pas en
doute mon intégrité je vous en prie
alors est ce que vous pensez pas que
dans la période actuelle à plus forte
raison demain est ce que vous pensez pas
que le fait qu'une société savante comme
la vôtre soit financé même partiellement
par l'industrie pharmaceutique ne porte
pas ombrage sur os sur la qualité ou la
partialité des avis ou des conseils ou
des préconisations que peut être amené à
émettre
c'est effectivement la question qui se
trouve vous et je vous rassure tout de
suite hein vous n'êtes pas la seule
société savante dans cette situation
c'est ce jeu me part stigmatisé les
médecins généralistes ouanna mais est ce
que vraiment il n'ya pas là un problème
alors je veux dire que mes yeux il ya un
problème c'est un problème qui au jour
d'aujourd'hui je ferai très voir résolue
et disparaître mais je vais aller plus
loin c'est un problème qui ne touche pas
que des sociétés savantes
je suis moi même par nature
universitaire puisque professeur de
médecine et que dans l'université aussi
on retrouve fait même problème
c'est à dire que l'ensemble du système
je ne parle pas de la recherche pour mes
occuper beaucoup ensemble des systèmes
fait que la participation y compris à la
recherche et pas uniquement sur le
médicament de l'industrie pharmaceutique
est toujours aujourd'hui incontournable
ça que je vais très clair et je pense
que dans ce que je vais vous proposer
comme un préambule à la fête échanges
ce n'est pas parce que je gère fait la
firme électrique je ne me sens pas libre
de parole d une part et d'autre part
dans le cadre de ses relations que l'on
est restituée je dirais presque que par
mes fichiers et par obligation et je
sais je pense avoir sur les dix ans tout
fait pour man